obviously men and women can work
together but there's going to be some
weird dynamic and you're going to be
like is this going to be offensive or
how is this going to be taken what can i
say exactly everybody who works for me
right now are men and i used to my best
friend used to work with me and she's a
girl and that was fine but we're like
very similar people pretty disagreeable
and i could tell her whatever and she's
not offended by anything
but i've noticed if i hire someone and
they're female
i have to be careful about how i talk to
them uh even giving criticism i like i i
feel like and maybe it's me but i feel
like i have to be a little bit nicer a
little bit more gentler whereas with a
dude i can be like can you just not do
this again and they're like yeah no
problem we'll do it again but if it's
female i'm like okay you did like this a
little bit wrong here's how to do it a
little bit better overall you're doing a
great job everything's fine please don't
be upset